So let's wrap up what we've talked about today.
We started off today by talking about state spaces and we used this to
frame our discussion of mean-ends analysis. Means-ends analysis is a very
general purpose problem solving method, that allows us to look at our goal and
try to continually move towards it. We then use means-ends analysis to try and
address a couple of different kinds of problems. But when we did so,
we hit an obstacle. To overcome that obstacle, we used problem reduction.
We can use problem reduction in a lot of other problem solving contexts, but
here we use it to specifically to overcome the obstacle we hit during means-ends
analysis. Problem reduction occurs and we take a big hard problem and introduce
it into smaller easier problems. By solving the smaller easier problems,
we solve the big hard problem. Next time we're going to talk about production
systems, which are the last part of the fundamental areas of our course. But
if you're particularly interested in what we've talked about today, you may wish
to jump forward to logic and planning. Those were built specifically on
the types of the problems we talked about today. And in fact in planning,
we'll see a more robust way of solving the kinds of obstacles that we hit,
during our exercise with means and analysis earlier in this lesson.